over 70 million fathers in the u.s.
inventive fathers athletic brave but not
everyone knows who their father is for
40 years we thought we did
until today I wasn't sure who your
father was that works a crazy sex
monogamy wasn't exactly a priority I've
always wondered where I got my zest for
lovemaking now we know our fathers been
out there this whole time operation
who's your daddy the top mission is
signing dad submission is gonna be
having Stone Crabs mission below that
getting you laid mom actually dated
Terry Bradshaw do you remember a woman
named Helen Baxter talk about a blast
from the past
she had the tightest ass you've ever
seen mouth and that time and a set of
knockers balls
damn near cost us a Super Bowl she's our
mom why did you just stop this
foolishness this is it what are you
doing here
anything were your sons excuse me for a
minute just like you the man arrived you
could easily be a serial killer you a
serial killer I am NOT a serial killer
you just emphasize the word serial like
I'm a killer but I'm not a serial killer
but I was totally an intense you're
still not saying I promise I'm not a
killer we can give you a ride but those
aren't too tight are they almost kill
you
[Music]
who was that I think it was a person the
universe has a tendency to point in the
right direction yes guys my negro spider
sense is tingling
there's the name Helen Baxter ring a
bell it does more than ringing Bell she
was like a dick whisperer
she's our mom all we did was cook
you